[Music]
hey what's up mkbhd here and welcome to
your first look and hands-on of
samsung's new mid-ear drops for 2022 the
flip 4 the fold 4 and a really
impressive looking new pair of watches
so this is everything you need to know
about all of it
so i'm gonna start with the phones and
the theme for the phones is definitely
refinement and this was already the
theme last year and the year before but
look in the relatively young world of
foldable phones right now for being
honest samsung is kind of dominating the
space like there's only a few foldable
phones that real people are actually
buying right now and the flip is
apparently the most popular folding
phone in the world so the flip 4 looks
and feels very much just like a flip 3.
like there's really three things that
are notably new about it and they're all
subtle so one is a slight aesthetic
trimming so the bezels are just a little
bit slimmer on the inside the rails feel
a little bit more trim and flat plus
there's a new set of colors then two is
it's a bit stronger and more durable so
that's always good to see in a folding
phone so the hinge is a little bit more
trim and still feels very sturdy to open
and close and of course stays half open
for all the software features that take
advantage of that and then three
is there's updated specs and i'm
thinking this is just me just using
context clues but i'm thinking that the
most noticeable improvement year over
year with this phone might actually be
battery life so this phone has the new
snapdragon 8 plus gen 1 which has had
excellent efficiency in some other
phones i've tested so far plus the
battery also bumps up from 3 300 to 3
700 milliamp hours that's a small thing
but it's a combo that could be great for
battery life plus it still fast charges
up to 50 in 30 minutes not bad other
than that though the hardware you're
looking at is very similar to the last
flip and really there's one big new
software feature which is a bunch of new
widgets and lock screen stuff on the
outside cover screen so you gotta love
the lock screen customization and the
functionality potentially even matching
your watch face to your phone so if this
was early days maybe the first one to
two generations of the phone that's when
you'd expect to see more tinkering with
like the size of the outside screen and
what it really should be capable of now
that they've settled on this size though
they're really just adding stuff that
you can do with it so you can change
quick settings take a selfie activate
the flashlight accept a phone call start
a new phone call all types of stuff like
that this is all good quality of life
stuff makes a lot of sense and i think
there's flip fans out there and austin
evans um who like the previous versions
who are gonna like this one too but at
the same time if you weren't convinced
on the flip whether it's because that
crease is still somewhat visible and
feelable when you scroll or because you
don't like the idea of having to open up
the phone every time you want to use it
or whatever else might have bothered you
none of that has changed either so this
new one probably won't change your mind
and neither will the new price because
it's the same as the old price 9.99 so
there are other phones that you could
get for this price other flagships you
know gaming phones slab style phones but
this one for 9.99 folds in half and it's
probably the most appealing folding
phone to most people but on the other
end of the spectrum though is the big
unfolding productivity monster the fold
for so this is actually the one i'm
personally most interested in and what
if i told you that the exact same set of
things is new on this phone too well
it's actually a little bit more than
that same stuff but the fold 4 also has
an improved slightly slimmer hinge which
is one of the most important overall
pieces of this phone and it feels firm
and confidence inspiring and very
satisfying to clap closed which is great
uh it has a nice satin finish on the
back with three colors the gold the
black and then this deep blue and then
it does in fact have a stronger gorilla
glass victus plus on the outside paired
with those aluminum rails they've also
updated the specs again with the same
new snapdragon 8 plus gen 1 inside the
highest end chip available and it does
have the same size 4 400 milliamp hour
battery as last year and then there's a
new camera system on the back as well so
these folding phones have never quite
had exactly the same set of cameras as
the highest end flagships you know the
ultra phones but they do typically get
right up underneath as the next best
thing so this fold here has a 50
megapixel primary camera a 12 megapixel
ultra wide and a 3x telephoto which will
let you get up to 30x space zoom i will
definitely be testing these new cameras
in these flipping folding phones in the
full review just to see how good they
are but if i was guessing if i was
guessing they'll probably perform pretty
similar to like an s22 plus which is to
say pretty great we'll see though and
then surprise surprise the fold four
also has one big new software feature
this time it's on the inside screen and
that's the dock at the bottom so you'll
notice when you open an app the entire
dock shrinks down to the bottom into
this sort of bar kind of like a windows
taskbar and from there you can easily
launch recent apps or hop back and forth
between apps quickly or even launch
straight into multitasking with two or
three apps on the screen at once it's a
small change but i think it makes a big
difference to keeping it easy and fluid
to quickly multitask on a phone like
this i don't know about you but when i
open the phone up and it's got this huge
seven inch screen inside i just want to
use a lot of stuff and multitask so
you've got the button to open up any app
all the way on the left you've got the
navigation buttons all the way to the
right i really do like this taskbar and
then just flipping through the device
for a bit the rest is very familiar to
what we've seen just again slightly
refined the outside cover screen is
actually three millimeters wider so it's
a slightly different aspect ratio again
thanks to slimmer bezels and you can
just barely tell by eyeballing it and on
the inside the bezels all the way around
again are just slightly thinner and the
crease through the middle to my eye is a
little bit less visible than it is on
the flip though it's not too different
from last year basically where if you're
looking at the content on the screen you
really don't notice it too much because
you don't pass your finger over it when
you're scrolling like maybe you would on
the vertically folding phone maybe if
you're a big stylist person you'll get
the whole s pen case and everything and
then you really notice the crease when
you draw a lot over the middle but yeah
i'm not one of those people so basically
it's there if you're looking for it but
it's not really too bad if you're not
you know what else though you probably
didn't notice if you weren't looking for
it the new under display selfie camera
right up here on the top right hand side
so samsung is using a new second
generation hidden selfie camera up here
and from my very limited experience it
is actually very impressive just how
well it's able to hide itself and stay
out of view even more so than last
year's first gen but the images that
come out of it definitely do not look
any better like that was the big
weakness of last year's folds hidden
camera and it appears to absolutely be
the weakness of this one again you can
see it does a fair amount of processing
with the still photos but i imagine a
video call won't look too pretty you
know i'll give it a shot maybe the
snapdragon 8 plus gen 1 will surprise me
but that's how it looks aside from that
though there's nothing fundamentally
different in any technology across the
board with this phone it is still very
much the productivity based tablet in
your pocket that we know and love just
settling into its form basically if we
expect any sort of different shape with
a foldable from samsung that's probably
just going to be a whole new phone just
a whole new model so in the meantime
this fold 4 launches again at the same
price as last year 17.99 so i'll review
both of these phones for sure but
low-key maybe the most interesting new
hardware to me here is actually the new
pair of watches here that samsung's
dropped there's a new galaxy watch 5 and
galaxy watch 5 pro some of you are
already remembering that i haven't
reviewed too many smart watches in the
past but maybe leave a thumbs up or a
comment on this video if you're
interested in something on these
basically if you've been paying
attention to apple rumors lately there's
been all kinds of stuff brewing about
maybe an apple watch refresh in
september and maybe an apple watch pro
but hey here comes samsung right out the
gate just ahead of that with a watch 5
and a watch 5 pro so the watch 5 has a
sweet new design with a reshaped
curvature and actually a flatter contact
area on the bottom so there's more
contact with your wrist for more
accurate readings of everything there's
two sizes 40 or 44 millimeters and each
one has a 15 bigger battery than before
thanks to the new shape for a claimed up
to 50 hours on a charge there's a nice
bright oled display on the front and
they're covering it with a sapphire
crystal glass this year and the whole
thing is ip68 water resistant software
wise looks pretty familiar plus they've
added things like detailed sleep
tracking with stages which is another
thing apple just added to the apple
watch but the watch 5 pro is interesting
because it's a more fitness and
adventure focused version of the same
thing so when you see them back to back
you'll notice it's it's thicker it's a
little more of a ruggedized version than
the standard watch they're only doing it
in a large 45 millimeter size and the
display is sort of inset behind these
titanium bezels and the sapphire crystal
cover glass they say is even stronger
than the standard i assume that's just
because it's thicker and they fit a 590
milliamp hour battery into this thing so
pretty massive battery without actually
looking like a super huge watch so they
promise one and a half times the battery
life of the standard watch putting it up
at 80 hours and that is what i'm curious
to test so the watch 5 bluetooth only
starts at 279 and then the watch 5 pro
at bluetooth only will start at 4 49. so
interesting new hardware developments
from samsung here very curious to see
that stuff let me know in the comments
what you're interested in seeing for the
full review i am definitely looking
forward to testing it but in the
meantime get subscribed if you haven't
already that's how you'll be among the
first to see the review that's been it
thanks for watching
catch you guys later
peace
[Music]